oh wait up behind you wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait
hurry wait wait wait god damn moment of
your life don't be selfish and have like
I do with my tank get in I can't get in
it's full it's not allowing me go into
the tank yeah I can't get into the tank
I hit wait but bob was next sorry I say
a good wait Bob said yeah I can't get in
but this tank is for all of us
ah one of us can use it except it was
gonna be mine and you're a freaking
[ __ ]
thanks for just one-seater oh there we
go now I figure how to shoot deck whoa
wait doesn't even know how to use the
tank okay Wade's gonna die mark mark let
me in mark where are you Bob
just back for you stay with wait I'll
find my own way your tank it was my tank
mark you should have seen the tank man
[ __ ] you man
I spotted that tank I cheat whoa Wow
whoa I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm trying to
kill cops you are not do I look like a
cop to you behind shrubberies I am
this explosion that Wade created at the
mouth of the tunnel is come in you too
uh well I've done nothing to you Arjun
effing nothing all right [ __ ] [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you
so the other thing that that might be
fun to do that's relatively easy is we
can go back to the normal airport where
there aren't military people guarding it
and we can do a helicopter jousting uh
okay that sounds like a good idea
I like we can all get health cops for
free [ __ ] all right we can see wait
I'm sorry can I call a cab or something
whoa okay thank you Wade thanks Wade
dude pick up everybody else all right
Jack get on our car I'm gonna go through
this tunnel that I'm sure is very sick
oh god oh god hey can I get in your car
guys
yeah yes run them over
mom are you all right honey a genie Jack
you look like a genius all right let's
do genie all right okay
wait wait this is not a wait wait wait
wait what fence for logically base Wade
okay that's not it up then hang you ran
that guy over that's okay what are you
doing I don't understand I don't like
this guy or this is what I deal with
every day of my life oh my god traffic
on the 405
real bad warning everyone go to first
person right now
till does okay I've got a force of your
car I've got a four-seater here I'm
getting involved i but got it come here
jack I got you okay I got you boo I got
it we got we got one of them SUV on a
gamepad it's like seconds yeah I found
what it was it's V V cycles to
first-person hey I'm right here buddy
hey thanks buddy
over there first we'll all chill out in
the car together
wait
Bob's cool [ __ ] you Wayne they stole my
goddamn echo Jackie's just holding my
mark holding up the middle finger
someone who's not driving Sam at the
airport he's the driver no no I can't
set a waypoint yeah I can't set a
waypoint to wait
[ __ ] you cops map is the waypoint keep I
got I got I got I got a little bit
faster oh it doesn't show up for me
that's do we I can't it's not there just
hand is like shaking it all right that's
when we lose our stars we should stop at
some point but [ __ ] you cops cooped in
with players plus 200 points vibrating
what's going on here I'm sorry I can't
control it
oh okay I got hook you eat stop shooting
God made chocolates many copses are in
front of us Paris who's good who's gonna
be a long drive enviable yes I don't
know if we're ever gonna actually get
there I think this might just be the
activity for the rest of the night nice
shoot the ones behind us not in front
all right we're actually doing pretty
good right now I'm gonna shine it's the
Stars what should I do
ah Super Cup strip club club I don't
think we're close to any strip clubs
unfortunately or tons of graphical boobs
Oh lighten up I just played huniepop so
there's a lot of you John Cena them I
was tried on to the beach so they
wouldn't see us again I didn't worry
pull over cops had turned green right
why didn't you say [ __ ] just now I don't
know I don't know what I actually did
say you just said no oh Jesus good turn
good turn good turn held it okay good
good motorcycle yeah I think I think
Wade's shot him in that I ran him over
all right shoot we can get past this
roadblock white dude we're not good
enough at video games for that
sweet spin I'd like to say that was on
purpose but that would be all right this
is the wrong way I know this is the
wrong way this is the wrong way Oh God
the wrong it's God
yeah you totally lost them cops yeah
they're gone right
are there any cops yeah okay so there
are still some cops around us yeah I
tried I tried
restore my tank
cuz he's an [ __ ] I didn't even get it
I didn't get it yet everyone got a jet I
had a tank it was supposed to be my tank
he shouldn't let me have it
he's an [ __ ] maybe oh good I'm glad
I'm very glad that happened all right
we're almost at the airport ish we've
only got and we're all still alive why
is everyone in the car but me dead
valves right here oh where where are you
where'd you spawn [ __ ] you also heliport
oh all right I might be about to die
yeah good work everybody
why am i 1.8 one miles away from the
airport now the way there wait jack is
that you yeah bro the stew just ran into
me and I okay we don't need a tail rotor
we're fine no we don't good tail roses
are for [ __ ] I will go where the
backup helicopter for when you guys
explode
we're going right toward I'm an expert
pilot I'm almost there guys I'm almost a
word Bordas flier Jack I just did like a
1080 that was some [ __ ] man bro I'm glad
I recorded that I lied I had no pick
them up or one back here okay Oh Marcus
anyway I'm almost there I'm almost there
I'm almost there [ __ ] ah I'm just gonna
stay with Jack no respawn just a sec no
wait no wood no no no no way [ __ ] you
wait [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
wait hey Jack yeah I defy you to take
off I want you to do my god oh my god I
seem to be stuck sorry sorry sorry sorry
sorry
you wanna if you want to line up a joust
the suspension bridge over there is a
great place to line up the joust joust
over the bridge
awesome and really tell us a lot about a
person's personality when they go into
this